from weapons to servants Boston Dynamics
robots are speculated to have been built
for all sorts of purposes but while they
may not know the company's intentions
for sure one thing is a given their
robots are guaranteed to catch your eye
and even creep you out to a certain
degree so in this video Let's Take a
look inside the factory where these
incredibly futuristic robots come to
life but before that let me give you a
brief background on this fantastic
Company Boston Dynamics Boston Dynamics
was founded as a spin-off between MIT
and Carnegie Mellon in 1992 by Mark
reibert who initially worked on Dynamic
robots at MIT in its early years the
company's research and development were
heavily funded by the US Military and
DARPA which has raised all types of
questions among the general public over
the years that's also a fundamental
reason why a large proportion of people
are skeptical of the underlying reason
behind the company's motivation to
develop these exceptionally lifelike
robots whenever a new video featuring
one of the Boston Dynamics Marvels goes
viral fresh stations arise on whether
the company is on a mission to make
killing machines household helpers or
something beyond our comprehension
entirely to clarify some of these
misconceptions I'll tell you guys what
the founder former CEO and chairman of
Boston Dynamics Mark reibert has to say
on the subject Mark publicly played down
prevalent misunderstandings about the
company's robots being used to kill
while speaking to the Associated Press
according to him robots like Cars
airplanes computers or lasers can be
used for good and evil however he also
simultaneously claimed that he doesn't
rule out the possibility of military
applications in the future the
implications of which are up for debate
also interestingly Mark aims to
eventually build vehicles that can go
anywhere on Earth without the trouble of
using roads or any other prepared
surface we're interested in building
vehicles that can go any place on Earth
without roads and other prepared
surfaces and so here's an example of the
robot previously on the snow and here
traveling on mud and here uh in water
all situation questions that wield and
tracked vehicles have a difficult time
but legged things Excel especially
people and animals and now the robots
we're making
they're actually able to pull this off
who knows what else the future has in
store for us you see the thing about
these robots is that even if you weren't
familiar with Boston Dynamics previously
you have most likely seen video clips of
big dog
spot Atlas
or handle
these videos have been around on the
internet that's the appeal of these
Dynamic and super mobile robots even
non-tech people feel compelled to watch
and ask questions these are some of the
most popular of Boston Dynamics
creations and if nothing else they
restore our trust in the magic of
Science and Technology inside the lab
now moving on to some fundamental
questions that I know have been on your
mind how did these robots even work how
are they manufactured and where are they
manufactured to satisfy your curiosity
I'll show you a look inside the
incredible Factory where these robots
are conceived planned and eventually
manufactured for decades Boston Dynamics
remained behind closed doors developing
robots that could only associate with
science fiction movies but last year was
lucky for the tech nerds out there
because the public finally got to see
what the inside of the factory where
these Dynamic robots come to life looks
like
foreign
the 180 000 square feet facility spans
three levels and has been built within
an existing space multiple Laboratories
are designed to support the workers and
their Creations from fabrication and
Engineering to bringing their elegant
robots to market the laboratory ensures
the provision of resources for all
moreover the laboratory boasts open
stairs and generous exterior and
interior glazing allowing natural
sunlight to illuminate every corner of
the facility Boston Dynamics also cares
about employee health and well-being
because the whole workplace gives a
super welcoming casual and playful feel
and that's not all various other
facilities make the Boston Dynamics
headquarters a uniquely people-centric
space the Lobby's robot Gallery the
multi-level Town Hall space the kitchens
the dining spaces along with Fitness
rooms and those designed specifically
from others all ensure that the
employees are prioritized above all else
while the lab appears pretty normal on
the outside the inside is nothing
remotely close to that it's like a
different plan on it entirely with
robots casually found in corridors
offices and kennels they Trot and dance
around like it's their home which in
their defense it really is the highly
passionate and hard-working roboticists
working there who build and often also
break the robots are used to their
presence for the most part and yet they
never run out of Fascination
unsurprisingly robots of such high
caliber require a highly diligent team
of dedicated professionals working
together to reach the goal although the
lab primarily includes engineers and
scientists with a genuine passion for
pushing the limits of Science and
Innovation Boston Dynamics also plans to
commercialize its technology to sell
products in the future now aligning
these goals hasn't exactly been easy
which explains why the company's
ownership has changed several times in
the decade going from Google in 2013 to
SoftBank in 2017 and finally to Hyundai
in 2021 until today still it's
impressive that Boston Dynamics has
managed to maintain a balance between
commercializing some of its products and
withholding others for further research
next up I'll show you how the company
decides which robots have the potential
for commercialization and which ones
deserve more research and further
development spot and stretch with the
company looking to create a successful
business model they release two of their
most popular commercial robots spot and
stretch
in 2020 and 2022 respectively this
multi-purpose Robo dog and a mobile
robo-arm have taken the world of
technology by storm making us seriously
consider the possibility of a future
that looks like an episode of The
Jetsons both spot and stretch have
already found multiple applications in a
wide range of Industries and with
Hyundai's acquisition of the company in
2021 there's a massive chance that
Boston Dynamics might be able to turn
these robots into highly profitable
Ventures the manufacturing capacity of
Hyundai mainly focusing on the latest
automobiles opens the door to unlimited
possibilities in the future but for
Boston Dynamics commercialization does
not mean that the company will neglect
its original research routes and
prospects for future development the
fact that it has certain robots reserved
for that purpose is a testament to its
commitment to science and investment in
creating humanoid robots Atlas and big
dog Atlas is one of those projects that
Boston Dynamics reserves purely for
research related objectives it's
basically a bipedal humanoid robot that
mimic human behavior to an almost
terrifying degree the company doesn't
plan to commercialize Atlas in the
foreseeable future not because it
doesn't have any real-life applications
because there are tons of those but
primarily because of how immensely
challenging it is to create such an
advanced biped robot nonetheless
research on this remarkable piece of
technology continues and Engineers
believe that optimizing the robot for
parkour performance will be the gateway
to achieving the full extent of bipedal
motor skills that can be applied to
other robots as well big dog on the
other hand is more likely to frighten
the average Joe than spark any kind of
excitement it was initially developed
for the military and after several
experiments the engineers got this
cheetah-like robot to run nearly 30
miles an hour after several experiments
which last I checked makes it the
fastest robot in the world unfortunately
big dog never made it out of the
Prototype phase but it did manage to
pull off something more significant it
led to the eventual development of spot
one of the most prominent robot dogs
you'll see today at this point it's
natural to wonder about the extent to
which these Rome can be developed is it
possible that one day they'll outsmart
us mere mortals and rule the world or as
an apocalyptic AI takeover a complete
myth let's check out some of the actual
capabilities of these robots so you can
decide for yourself actual capabilities
of Boston Dynamics robots sure the
demonstrations you've seen on video so
far are remarkably impressive and
Sensational but some roboticists in the
industry have criticized Boston Dynamics
for being a bit misleading most of these
demonstrations are like orchestrated
routines instead of Just Happening out
of the blue at any given instant like
humans moving around they require a lot
of tweaking to get right you can't just
flip a switch and expect Atlas or spot
or big dog to just do their thing yes
these routines are enough to Mesmerize
viewers but remember that these robots
are pretty Limited in their capacity
depending on how much humans program
them to do so don't worry robots don't
actually pose a threat to the human race
or existence at least not in the near
future still these robots have advanced
over time and compared to demonstrations
in past where they were essentially
blind just following Moves In A Familiar
environment now they rely more on their
own perception to navigate that means
there's less programming and more
intuition if that's what you can call it
now that you know you don't need to fear
a robot Uprising and instead see them as
progress in scientific development do
you look forward to what Boston Dynamics
plans to do in the future how will the
company make its Mark in the competitive
market let's dive deeper into that
Hyundai and Boston Dynamics the future
of Mobility with unprecedented
technological advancements and
innovation in recent decades multiple
other robotics companies are competing
to stand out in the field of autonomous
mobile robots particularly those with
industrial applications but personally I
think the Hyundai and Boston Dynamics
partnership is Miles Ahead of the rest
this acquisition represents nothing less
than a notable leap forward towards our
progress as a species in a
hyper-competitive industry such as
robotics manufacturers must prioritize
versatility and robustness while
maintaining a balance with cost of
and Edge the Boston Dynamics has in
Spades the company has something that is
missing in most other robotics companies
which is solid research experience you
can see that in the commercial robots
that I mentioned earlier in the video
both spot and stretch are evolutions of
various research prototypes so their
Kinks and problems have been worked out
after years of research on the other
hand Hyundai brings Mass manufacturing
capabilities to the table so in
combination they can definitely
commercialize the field of Robotics
further this gives the partnership an
undeniable Advantage for at least a few
more years to come however even though
it is super exciting and novel keep in
mind that robotics is still a relatively
challenging field and requires a lot of
funding and assistance before we can
expect to see significant development
robots have enabled us to explore facets
of our world and Humanity that were
considered almost impossible previously
from unreachable environments to the
depth of the oceans to mysteries of
outer space we wouldn't be where we are
today if it weren't for robots and now
the technological world is eyeing these
a ai-powered wonders of science to
improve the quality of an average human
life by supporting us in all kinds of
daily tasks with the help of Hyundai
Boston Dynamics will be able to expand
future mobility and revolutionize the
concepts of autonomous vehicles
Logistics and Urban Air Mobility Boston
Dynamics is already heavily credited for
moving robots from Mere imagination into
our homes offices and classrooms and by
working with a renowned automotive
manufacturer like Hyundai it will have
access to more Factory space and
assembly lines this in turn would enable
the company to realize its commercial
vision of mass manufacturing the robots
it has been doing inside a lab so far
I'm hopeful that the future of Boston
Dynamics is bright and full of new
possibilities
that's it from my end if you enjoyed
this video make sure to hit the
Subscribe button also if you're
interested in learning more about the
latest developments in science and
technology check out the other videos on
the cards thank you for watching and
I'll see you next time